whether you want antiques or anchovies
Farm produce or framed pictures weekends
at St George's Market in Belfast bring
together the broadest of spectrums with
a bit of music thrown in for good
measure
Traders have adapted to post-brexit
regulations there's no shortage of cured
meats or Continental cheeses here what
there is a shortage of is political
consensus and the voter's patience is
wearing thin we need a
first Minister for all the never
Neverland stuff has to go away
and I think we just keep moving forward
without 25 years is a good Friday
agreement and everybody's sick of the
nonsense up at storming we just want a
government that governs the stalemate is
about the Northern Ireland protocol
which governs the movement of produce
and goods from Mainland UK to Northern
Ireland after brexit the unionist dup
party wants the protocol scrapped
because it says it undermines Northern
Ireland's links to the rest of the UK
parties effectively blocking the entire
devolved government until it gets its
way people here in Northern Ireland are
often very reluctant to talk about
politics it's a deeply sensitive subject
but the overall sentiment here appears
to be one of sheer disillusionments with
the politicians in general
Civic organizations and Charities are
increasingly having to fill the gaps
across Community fundraising by the
breeder Sports Club supports hundreds of
people who are struggling with domestic
energy bills
work I even visited a lady during the
week with four children
who was dying to her last ten pounds and
she was making decisions based on
whether or not to put three pounds on a
gas or electric card whether to use the
money for a bus fare to send her
children to school
or whether just to buy food Chris
O'Reilly is also involved in the project
he says the numbers needing support are
rising dramatically this year and the
lack of a functioning government is
affecting business too some of the
levers that they've been able to pull in
the past has been been a discounted
rates policy or or or rates holiday
which is which is what we're asking for
at the moment but we can't ask anybody
because there's nobody in in situ to be
able to do that next week the British
Minister responsible for Northern
Ireland will meet Party leaders in
Belfast for last-ditch talks an election
looks inevitable but there's no
guarantee that carving up the vote yet
again will produce a clean outcome
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Belfast